hey everyone james murphy here this is
emcoding and let's just jump into it
with some controversial events happening
in the world of python
if you haven't already heard the news
the c python developers just pushed out
a breaking change to the language
modifying long-standing behavior of how
into string and string to end
conversions work putting a default limit
on how many digits are allowed
previously there was no limit on the
size of integer you could use as long as
you have enough memory to hold it this
was one of the cool features of python
that new programmers would often explore
just print math factorial of 10 000 and
there it is
but if you download python today instead
you'll be greeted with an error telling
you the answer is too big
the default limit is 4 300 digits
users must now call this sys set and max
stir digits to increase the digit limit
or set it to 0 to disable the limit
now it prints just as before
this limit only applies to conversions
from into string and string to end that
aren't in a base that's a power of two
so printing binary and hex are not
affected
but humans normally write numbers in
base 10 so this does affect the most
common use case also note that this is
not a limit on the size of integers
outright only on conversions to and from
strings so you can still operate on big
numbers without any changes you just
might not be able to print the results
that's why the error here is on line
four where the print statement is and
not on line three where the answer is
actually computed
part of what makes this so controversial
was that this change which undoubtedly
breaks some existing projects was pushed
out with essentially no warning to the
community not just to the latest
development branch of python 311 but to
python 37 3839 and 310 as well in a
patch release
patch releases are generally meant to be
made of small changes that are
completely backwards compatible or that
fix outright bugs errors crashes or
security vulnerabilities
as such tooling such as automated test
runners may use the latest patch by
default and package managers may ignore
the patch number when considering
version compatibility
this means that projects depending on
the old behavior will have their
automated tests broken and their users
who are on the latest patch will
immediately start experiencing these
breaking changes even if the project
hasn't made any new release
so why would they push out a breaking
change like this
going to the c python source this github
issue claims the previous behavior of
in-string conversion is a security
vulnerability which explains why it's
able to be pushed out so quickly even
though it was a breaking change
this vulnerability was initially
reported in may of 2020 and officially
went public on september 1st 2022
according to red hat's cve page although
the github issue was apparently created
a month before in august
so what is this vulnerability
well see python uses an n squared
algorithm in the number of digits for in
string conversions when the bases aren't
compatible
here a mere million and one digits took
four and a half seconds to complete
we can confirm this n squared behavior
empirically by looking at the timing
plots for conversions we can clearly see
super linear growth in this plot
and if we look at a log log plot and
compute the least squares fit we see
that the estimated power is very close
to 2.
so empirically at least this really is
an n squared algorithm
under the hood the actual algorithm that
python uses is very similar to these
basic conversion functions
it's really not much more than repeated
division or multiplication depending on
the direction
these may appear to be just of n
algorithms but it's actually o of n
squared because multiplication and
division are not constant time
operations since we're working with
arbitrarily large numbers
so these divide by 10 or multiply by 10
are actually order n operations
themselves
this means that converting between
integers and strings is more expensive
than you might expect and it opens
python up to a denial of service attack
on any code that tries to convert
between them
in particular any kind of parser or api
that takes base 10 values as strings may
be vulnerable including the built-in
json module parsing libraries like
pedantic and api frameworks that depend
on these
a bad actor can send a moderately large
number with say a million digits to
cause an api to freeze for around 5
seconds like we saw
the new default digit limit fixes this
issue by raising an exception that your
code can catch unless you have
explicitly opted in to allowing this
expensive conversion
of course primarily in favor of the
change there are operators and users of
services that have these vulnerable apis
the original github issue argues that
the change is necessary in part because
of how incredibly common it is to take
unsanitized user input from the internet
and pass it directly to int
on the other side are authors and users
of libraries that use big numbers
meaning this is probably going to hit
math libraries the hardest
this may complicate things for their
users and of course now the code that
they've already put out there is broken
some in this camp have argued that doing
anything with unsanitized user input is
already a vulnerability waiting to
happen so it should really be up to
vulnerable apis to sanitize their inputs
not the python language to limit how
numbers work
others are confused why we're using
these n-squared algorithms when there
are known faster algorithms readily
available potentially switching to
faster algorithms could make the denial
of service infeasible eliminating the
need for the digit limit at all
and then of course there are a large
number of people that are perfectly fine
with the change as they're most likely
not affected by it but just upset by the
lack of transparency or opportunity to
have their opinions considered and to
potentially prepare for the break
regardless of how this issue pans out
the core dev team did apologize for the
lack of transparency on the issue
although it is sometimes necessary for
security vulnerabilities and they are
welcoming further discussion on the
issue if you have an opinion on the
matter especially if you're affected by
the change the correct place to
respectfully voice your opinion is the
python discourse linked below
please keep your suggestions and
criticism constructive and don't use the
discourse to rant
and that's where i pass it off to you
what do you think about this breaking
change is protecting vulnerable apis
that uri may unknowingly be using every
day worth it even if that means some
math libraries are broken or should
vulnerable code be on the hook to
sanitize its inputs don't forget to
subscribe and i'll see you next time
as always thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting me